. So as we talked about earlier this week, those
who are still Republicans overwhelmingly still
support former President Donald Trump. The
numbers of thinking back to the Monday show,
something like 80 percent of Republican
voters still view Donald Trump favorably.
Something like 70 percent of Republican
voters want Donald Trump to run for president
in 2024. That's not the problem. Increasingly, the
problem for the Republican Party is that there are
fewer and fewer Republicans left than. What I
mean by that is that the number of Americans
who identify as Republicans or as independents
leaning Republican is down to just 40 percent
as of the first quarter of twenty twenty one
now. On the other hand, the number of Democrats
and Democratic leaning independents is up to 49
percent. That's a nine point gap, 49 to 40 for
Democrats and Democratic leaning independents over
Republicans and Republican leaning independents.
This is now the biggest Democratic advantage that
Gallup has measured, dating back almost a decade
to the fourth quarter of 2012 when Barack Obama
was reelected. And this is something that Gallup
measures regularly. And what Gallup has found
is that there are some very specific reasons why
so many voters have abandoned the Republican
Party. I don't think any of these are particularly
surprising. Number one, Joe Biden winning the 2012
presidential election and being inaugurated just
after the humiliating and disastrous January 6th
Trump riots has pushed millions of people away
from the Republican Party and either towards being
independents or towards the Democratic Party.
The expansion of coronavirus vaccination has
helped move people away from the Republican Party.
The passage of Joe Biden's one point nine trillion
dollar covid stimulus package has moved people
away from the Democratic sorry, away from the
Republican Party towards the Democratic Party.
Now, to be very clear, this is not the biggest gap
we've ever seen between Republican and Democratic
registration. If you go back to sort of the
2006 to 2009 era, Democrats actually had a
double digit advantage in registration there.
If you go back further, almost, what would it
be? Almost 30 years ago, in 1992, around the
time of the election of President Bill Clinton,
Democrats also had a double digit advantage at
that point in time. So this is obviously very
bad news for Republicans in theory, if it
translates into how people vote in 2022 and 2024.
But we should temper our expectations. And there's
a few things to keep in mind here. First of all,
in a country where often half the country doesn't
vote or, you know, if turnout is really high,
35 percent of the country still doesn't vote.
Having a nine point a ten point a twelve point
party registration advantage doesn't necessarily
win you elections. If you're looking at it from
the Republican perspective, having a nine point
party registration deficit doesn't have to lose
you elections depending on who actually goes out
to vote. But we can actually control that with
turnout. If we get out the vote, then we can turn
that a party registration advantage into a real
world benefit. There's a bigger problem we can't
control, which is that within states you have such
outrageous partizan gerrymandering right now
that that was done by the Republican Party, where
just to win half of House seats, Democrats need
significantly more than half the votes. And that
is also a real problem for the Democratic Party.
But probably the most important takeaway here
is we've been saying that Republicans have
launched more than 250 voter suppression
bills across more than 40 states because too
many people voted in 2020. The results in 2020
were proof to Republicans. We didn't do enough
voter suppression. We need to suppress more vote.
And that's why they are now filing and
pushing more than 250 voter suppression
bills. There's another aspect to this, this
party registration data. Republicans seeing
we are hemorrhaging voters. We are seeing
attrition of Republican voter registration
that also is making them realize we have to
suppress more votes. We have to pass some of
these two hundred and fifty bills. The Republican
Party believes that when they are winning,
it's a free country and they're winning
because they're winning the battle of ideas.
But when they're not winning, this is a socialist,
tyrannical, authoritarian nightmare executed by
communists such as Joe Biden. And they will
do anything they can on that basis to win
elections. Now, one one last thought here,
just because there are fewer Republicans.
Gerrymandering aside, voter turnout aside, just
because there are fewer Republicans doesn't
necessarily mean that a lot of those former
Republicans are going to go out and vote for
Democrats. They may not vote at all. They may no
longer be Republicans, but they will still vote
for Republicans when they see who it is that's on
the ballot. Unless you can turn this registration
deficit or margin, depending on
which side you're looking at it, from
into election victories, into political victories,
they are merely interesting numbers. Now,
the question is whether Democrats
can actually do anything with it.